madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
tout augmente même les nuits de sommeil
une inflation bien sympathique grâce au
retour de leurs divers nous avons tous
pu dormir une heure de plus ce matin
mais un changement d'heure qui a posé
deux difficiles problèmes d'horaires à
la sncf comme jean-paul flory a pu le
constater cette nuit à 1h du matin heure
d'été c'est à dire à minuit heure
d'hiver
les trains qui sont partis sont partis à
l'heure à l'heure d'été les trains sont
partis à l'heure de tela et pour les
pour les grandes lignes
alors divers jeux leur hiver tandis est
pour quand ces derniers par le fort 17
donc avec une heure de retard
les autres partent avec une heure
d'avancé c'est le temps par avec une
heure de retard berlin comprend pas très
bien mais si c'est leur valeur
l'heure d'hiver vous n'avez plus
d'heures de référence l'assistance
c'est là qu'elle l'heure d'hiver où
l'heure d'été à l'heure d'hiver à
l'heure d'hiver pour le camp les autres
bons comme il ya ces grèves
il ya pas de train pour au départ ça ne
pose pas de problème pour l'instant
alors pourquoi pour le train de 48 qu'il
est parti avec 21 il n'est pas parti où
il va partir avec une rando frère mais à
partir avec une heure de retard à 0 17
heures de retard sur l'heure d'été une
heure d'avancé
dans la vente
une histoire à la raymond devos presque
enfin j'espère que malgré tout ce
cheminot dont la solide assurance du
départ a fini par se troubler j'espère
que ce cheminot a réussi à rentrer chez
lui par le bon train à la bonne heure
[Musique]